[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online she always looked this good with
no makeup oh yeah better even better
without makeup check out this throwback
pic Dax Shepard posted to Instagram
celebrating the fact Kristen Bell
eventually married him despite the nasty
dip habit he had at the time Amber Rose
keeps flaunting her romance with dancing
with the stars pro Val Chmerkovskiy
another thing she's definitely not
hiding her fresh makeup free face we are
thrilled were thrilled to see Candace
Cameron Bure rocking some new auburn
locks first on social media and again on
the red carpet it's the Pepsi zero sugar
Super Bowl halftime show
lady gaga is taking her Super Bowl
performance prep so seriously she even
built a giant rehearsal space in her
backyard so this is Jessica on this
beautiful police officers Jessica Alba
found out what it feels like to have
your face tattooed on someone else's
body so honored when it comes to cute
kids Jennifer Lopez's art winning and
winning and Max and Emme are getting so
big they're all right oh they are
they're so big and so amazing and happy
Jude Law's 16 year old daughter iris has
lots to be happy about two she's
officially the new face of burberry's
I'm site thrills
[Music]
you